members of Congress are also headed home
for Memorial Day even though the fight
over raising the debt ceiling is still
going on sources tell CBS News the two
sides are making progress with just six
days to go before the treasury's
deadline Nancy Cordes is at the White
House Nancy good morning where do we
stand at this point
good morning well our sources are
telling us that Republican lawmakers and
White House negotiators are getting very
close to a deal to raise the nation's
borrowing limit now there are still some
issues to be worked out but they do
appear to be closing in on a set of
terms that most importantly would Stave
off a default for about two years
we are on approach
on so many issues new signs a deal could
be close at hand after another late
night for negotiators we've been talking
to the White House all day we're going
back and forth and um it's not easy
source is familiar with the talk say the
deal under discussion would cap overall
federal spending levels for the next two
years military and Veterans funding
would increase slightly next year while
domestic spending would dip slightly or
remain flat speaker McCarthy and I have
a very different view of who should bear
the burden of additional efforts to get
our fiscal house in order Republicans
have been insisting on Cuts in exchange
for their votes to raise the nation's
borrowing limit which must happen within
the week or the treasury secretary says
she'll start to run out of funds to pay
the nation's bills 25 billion dollars
worth of Social Security checks are
scheduled to go out the door next Friday
the ratings agency Fitch just placed
America's AAA credit rating on a
downgrade watch list a default would
throw this economy into a session it
would mean an immediate spike in
interest rates it would cause real
economic harm to families across the
country Republicans had been seeking 10
years worth of spending caps that would
have driven domestic spending down by 20
to 30 percent some conservatives are
already questioning whether the emerging
compromise goes far enough you're
talking about raising the debt ceiling
significant out of money we got to get
significant you know changes in return
but this deal if it does come together
is not designed to get every Republican
vote nor will it get every Democrat it
just needs to get enough of both to pass
the House and Senate in time to prevent
what would be the first default in U.S
history Tony
time is running short though Nancy thank
you very much